I'm curious for both of you
um what you've never as far as I know
you've never done anything like this
being like the lead
um or one of the leads and with all this
action and everything that went with it
so for both of you what actually
surprised you about making a series like
this and doing action on this scale Etc
suppose we have myself and Sophia we're
literally we mirrored each other in so
many ways and it was great to have
someone that was there that could really
appreciate the gravity of what was
happening to both of us and how much
work we really kind of had to put in and
I think what surprised me um
I think once you're in the doing of
anything and you're you're really really
busy you kind of you just it just
becomes a machine and we just went
through the motions you know we just
knew there was a mental work ahead of us
and we really need to just keep the gas
of pedaling the gas and yeah I think we
just really really leaned on each other
and which I was surprised about in a way
that it was just great to have a cast
mate who became really sensitive one of
your best friends you know to like
really really just she was just there
constantly when like when like one of us
fell we'd catch each other you know one
of us having a bad day we pick each
other up because it was an awful long
shoot and the days are really really
really really low you know
seconded yeah and it was a little bit
generic and I apologize but what are you
actually most excited for Witcher fans
to see in the prequel I mean I think
there's there's an introduction to so
many Incredible characters for for one
and there's just incredible Landscapes
to the to the initial Witcher universe
that people haven't seen that we get to
establish so those two things it's so
rich in in
in
texture and body and heart and passion
that I'm excited for them to just meet
the world that we've created
yeah and like I think there's so many
things that can open up as well I mean
we have the conjunction of the Spheres
and we have to force prototype which are
in the show we have all these new
characters that no one's met before with
like the band of seven I think really
people are going to gravitate towards
the group
of of Warriors that are traveling across
the continent I think yeah I think it's
going to be a smash I normally don't say
this but I'm curious how much did you
geek out when Michelle with your first
scenes with Michelle because she's
effing awesome she's amazing I mean for
me I I
was I was really nervous that day
because there's a lot to live up to I
think up to that point me and Lawrence
had both you know had enough prep time
together to really kind of like share
the nerves but I didn't know necessarily
how to deal with that with Michelle
until she completely
uh you know like demystified herself and
just it we just were able to just play
around with her but it it has and will
always be an honor to have worked with
her on this project and it was it was
incredible
ditto
back at you on that note I have to stop
but um I really did enjoy the prequel
and uh I know fans are gonna dig it uh
good luck with the rest of your speed
dating